The museum was inaugurated on November 1, 1982. It was built in the Kruria Castle,
on the left side of its entrance. The architects of the museum were Pranvra Hoja and Piro Veso.
The museum was built in Kruria because it was the centre of the Albanian resistance
against the Ottomans in the 15th century, and its name was well known all across Europe.
Three sieges, 1450, 1466, 1467, failed and the Ottoman conquered the castle only in 1478.
The museum building has the character of a memorial.
In the architectural exterior, two main volumes are distinguished,
the extended horizontal part with the main halls and the vertical one built
similar to the northern typical colours. The interior is arranged so as the spaces
are combined successively, without interruption, according to the concept of the presentation of
history. History, architecture and art are perceived as one. Elements such as heavy beams
and stone arches are used. Artwork, stone carvings, wood carvings, iron, graphics, glass paintings,
play the role of supplementary historical material. As you enter the museum you will
find a sculptural group that presents George Castrioti in the middle of his people.
The warriors are not named. Their garments and headdresses demonstrate the participation of
all regions in the war. The woman figure shows her participation in battles.
Janak Pa O and Jain Kajdari are the authors of this one.